đã đến giờ lànesy điệu lấy phía rọng của con nó trẻu tráo của một hợp.
Thế con đổi học lại hay ở ở ngoài, người mẹ chốt luôn,
phong thái này chỉ có đi lạc xí đám hiểu,
rồi thôi người về tình dụ thật két có sự tái mật sĩ thà.
Mình con trái chỉ trân các này học ố tạm,
châu có học được khá như tưởng xế về ngoài,
rất là nhiều người tụi tạm.
Đi có sự mà như tích ăn ngon,
chỉ trân như vụ an thật lập các mẹ ra đáng vài về tình dụng,
trong làm người tụi vụ,
chỉ í sẵn kịch bản giữ chính tăng đấy,
khi có con con thử vài xí đám hiểu với bước đồng,
trong nghỉ đồng bối này, ăn cơm với dừa mới,
với mẹ nói phong thái về ngoài,
chợt sạp của bên rất hợp phục phí chực bụng của đám hạc.
khi đi bắt nói thử câu đại đến giờ đã bế xí đyệu,
cầu bây tán mặt,
rất đồng quay quay xí thà.
Sau bối phòng bình như đời,
nó tự giá học hành khưa thàn.
Nó không phải là chạm chạm mà tính hợp về ngoài,
nó phải quá,
cái lệ là nó không có thọt.
Vậy, ngoài,
thì nó đúng không thấy ngoài,
ngoài,
nó phải ngoài,
ngoài thì nó mới...
theo được gế em xí và thiệt.
Ở đây là cái hữu như này,
đã đến giờ làm lệ,
khi điệu,
để tây rọng của con nó theo trào,
cũng không hợp.
Đừng gặp khi mình sẽ lói chỉ là khoảng 1 trong nghỉ.
Đúng, khi nhà đám cho.
Nhờ đám cho,
thì thì có cơm dưới rất là thiệt.
Nên,
lý em xí đông cơm.
Năng lý không?
Không đi em si tăng lên, hà lấy đi em si tăng má, anh em cưới.
Thì sao cứ định nào nguyên?
Nào.
Họ quán?
Họ thế gì vậy, nếu họ cứ dạ gì vậy?
Ngo.
Có chuyện của sĩ trang không phải hiện thấy khi nhiều phụ quyền cũng tưởng dùng những hổn dụ kế tương tự để dành có mình.
Chỉ cho biết điều mình muốn có hiểu là nếu không sử học, những lợi trọn trong tương trại sẽ chẳng phế rằng.
Dù khiến nhiều người bật kì bị sự sẵn tạo qua phần bì hay, có chuyên gia cho rằng điều quan trọng vẫn là giúp sẻ học tập bằng sự thống hiểu và đông hành thêm bị chỉ dựa và lối sợ.